the Atlantic reports age Phi holds
online footprint can begin before
they're even born it starts when parents
upload sonograms to social media 92% of
toddlers have their own digital identity
by the age of two that's according to a
2010 survey by the internet security
firm EVG some call this Sharon ting this
is when parents actively share their
child's digital identity of the
Atlantic's Taylor Lorenz the writer of
the article now joins us welcome Taylor
thanks for having me Sharon Ching we'll
get to that in a minute but you talked
to 20 kids and so what did how do they
see this world this digital world that
that arrives to them maybe if they don't
they might not even know it exists yeah
well you know I think the kids had a
broad range of reactions it was
everywhere from completely freaking out
about you know everything that their
parents are posted being really angry
getting mad to others that kind of said
that it made them feel a little bit
famous you know they Google those
thoughts themselves they saw a bunch of
pictures and it made them then made them
feel important so what kind of things
did they post it would be upsetting to
the kids because I don't know of any
parent who intentionally would share
something that they think put their kids
in a bad light of course and I know you
know a lot of parents share a lot of
this stuff with a good heart you know
they think that their child is adorable
they might think that's silly dance
they're doing is cute and funny but it
can be really mortifying I mean we've
all had even friends probably parents
post stuff that we kind of later look
back on and and feel a little bit
embarrassed by so should they be asking
their kids is it okay to post this I
think it depends on how old your kid is
and you know I think a lot of kids you
know even at the age of 10 don't really
comprehend the long-term effects so it's
really up to parents to use their best
judgment in terms of what to post and
maybe what to keep private
how can over sharing impact a child
later in life could it affect their
future getting into schools or jobs
absolutely I mean I think that just with
the amount of you know time that these
kids are sort of spending online and
they have a bunch of richer digital
footprint so you know I did a story last
year on college admissions officers who
almost by default Google a lot of kids
now sometimes and you know whereas
before you might have really been able
to tell the story of your own life
through your personal essay they can
easily google you they see that wow you
know you
only started in this community service
club actually since high school and you
know you don't really have this long
history or maybe your sports stuff is
online when you're younger growing up is
a process of forming your identity
trying on new identities taking them off
and all of that how much and did the
kids talk at all about that when their
parents kind of create their identity
for them and they don't get an
authorship in their own life definitely
um it seems to be you know around was
sort of right before middle school when
kids really start to kind of want to
define themselves online it's often when
a lot of kids ask for their own social
media account sometimes seeing sort of
what their parents have constructed for
them and wanting to push back on that
and say hey I want to post my own
pictures or I'm not really like that or
you know you think it's cute when I'm
doing something weird but I'm actually
mortified Oh anyone who follows me on
social media knows that I am guilty of
sharing a lot my 62 year old but we also
noticed that schools are posting online
sites as well and have their own
accounts should we be talking to the
principals and the teachers yeah what
they post
schools clubs sports teams you know a
lot of these people and you know they're
doing it out of the goodness of their
heart they want parents to feel involved
they want to be able you know to check
on Instagram see what they're up to but
yeah I think it's important for parents
to have a conversation and say you know
is this gonna live forever you know are
you tagging these kids names you know
and kind of having just opening that
discussion what's in some of these
digital literacy programs yeah so there
are more digital literacy programs sort
of aimed at actually educating kids
themselves about their online footprint
so you know making sure that they're
kind of aware of the fact that they have
a presence online so they're not shocked
by it later and also just thinking
critically about social platforms a lot
of times you know parents won't know
that their kids are online you know
setting up an Instagram account when
they're nine so it's a lot of those
literacy programs are aimed at educating
schools and kids because now the kids
are googling themselves and checking out
to see what you're doing yeah so you're
saying to parents be mindful about what
you post I drop it and realize that you
know like everything I know that it
lasts forever
okay got it thank you very much no
worries